during his long military career retired
four-star Army General Stanley
McChrystal led US and international
forces in Afghanistan he was also in
charge of Joint Special Operations
Command the nation's premier military
counterterrorism force now he's on a new
mission called serve America together
it's one year of paid national service
for young Americans 18 and older they
would help communities in critical areas
like education the environment and
disaster relief
general McChrystal joins us from
Washington general good morning I want
to get to America serves I think it's a
wonderful idea
but I want to begin with some news of
day actually news of the weekend
President Trump becoming the first
president to step foot in North Korea
your reaction well it was a little
nostalgic from one standpoint I spent a
year assigned to Pam Lujan when I was a
young captain so the exact spot where he
and kim jungeun stood were places that i
served and then my father-in-law landed
at the Pusan Perimeter in the summer of
1950 fought all the way to the Yalu
River and survived as a young tanker and
then my father served a year in combat
and the bitter hill fights in 1952 and
53 so kind of wrapped up into the idea
of Korea when I when I see the potential
for progress like every American
I am hopeful cautiously optimistic when
I see Kim Jong moon I see the grandson
of Kim il-sung the dictator who in 1948
began the brutal regime and so I'm
really cautious about it does it come at
a high cost do you think general for the
United States you know some say this
certainly gives legitimizes Kim Jong un
but is a high cost for the United States
do you agree well game in one way I do
but in another way I'd almost argue that
we make more of North Korea the North
Korea deserves it's a small country sure
it's developing nuclear weapons and it's
kind of a pain around the world but I
don't think we should legitimize their
ability to threaten us or their ability
to threaten the world more than it
deserves because I actually think it
encourages that behavior so what would
you consider success in this next round
of negotiations because everyone's
saying look we got this great photo-op
but what else have we really gotten here
not
yeah I think success obviously is trying
to denuclearize North Korea but if you
look at Kim jong-eun that is a long
stretch for him it's unlikely he could
retain power internally if he gave up
nuclear weapons with his own entourage
and so I think that's a real question
mark I think if we can maintain
stability I think that's about as good
as we get general I wanted to ask you
quickly about Iran because you let
Forces both in Iraq and Afghanistan with
the rising tension in Iran Dee are you
worried about the risk of war there I am
there is the first the reality that
we've got to see some things through
Iranian eyes and if you go back to 1953
and the overthrow of Prime Minister most
of a the Iranians feel as though they
have been contained they have been
battered they have been invaded and so
whether we agree with their perspective
or not there is a legitimate viewpoint
from them and so the reality is I think
what we've got to do is avoid this idea
that we both think we've got the version
of history exactly right and therefore
we bump against each other thinking that
the others just won't listen in reality
I think everybody needs to calm down a
little bit there's behavior the Iranians
do that's unacceptable but the reality
is I think they are a fragmented society
not very supportive of the regime and
our best play is not to unify them but
to work the other forces all right
general from one fragment it's decided
to another society our own that is
sometimes described as fragmented these
days you are part of an organization
with an idea to help heal some of those
wounds through national service why do
you think it's a good idea for every
young American to spend a year in
national service well I'd go back to
something that was said in 1838 by young
rising Abraham Lincoln and describing
what would destroy the United States the
greatest threat he said there'd never be
a foreign power who could do that if we
would die it would be by national
suicide I think that's true we're about
to celebrate the fourth of July and
we're all going to feel very good about
the formation of our nation and an
exceptional nation but most of us are
citizens by accident of birth we haven't
done much for it
we we hold on to our rights but
sometimes we forget our responsibilities
I think most of us learn responsibility
to our nation to ourselves and most
importantly to our fellow Americans
through experience the ability to serve
so I what I think we need is the
opportunity to bring young Americans
together for a year of paid full-time
service and what it would produce is
alumni of an experience that would
change them for the rest of their lives
general how do you make this happen well
first it's a bipartisan idea so it
doesn't have to be Republican or
Democratic it can be from all of us I
think it's a public-private partnership
it's not a great big Secretary of
Service and brings everybody together
instead it's a constellation of existing
the Peace Corps AmeriCorps City Year
Teach for America all of these added
with many other movements brought
together to create opportunities there
would have to be some funding from the
federal government some from private
philanthropy and other sources but also
we have to create an environment where
because it's not mandatory it is
socially accepted culturally accepted
but also a young person who does it
comes out of it better maybe we give
them education credits maybe we have a
GI Bill equivalent you know the idea of
free college is great but the reality is
we value what we work or pay for and
you're saying paid service instead of
volunteer to your last point we value
what we pay for well it has to be paid
to Gail because you don't want it to be
only people whose parents can afford to
yeah support them for you very good
point
general McChrystal very glad to see or
it's disappointed to see you were gonna
be in DC and not at our table but we'll
take you however we can see you I was
waiting for you this morning
well it's my pleasure Gail thank you
good to see you sir on TV